alright y'all so today I'm going to
surprise someone who I'm extremely
grateful for that works on the Kelly
Clarkson show with an ambush thank you
[Music]
if you haven't seen me do this before I
write a letter to someone on my staff to
thank them for all their hard work and
then publicly embarrass them with
compliments and kind words because they
deserve recognition for being so awesome
what's up Jason okay so this is called
ambush thank you I wrote you a letter
Lisa thank you so much for being the
greatest teleprompter goddess in all of
the universe
so I'm pulling up my pen and I'm pulling
out my paper for today's ambush thank
you I want to save everything I'm going
to say until I see this person face to
face and I'm gonna get too emotional if
I get into it now so I want y'all to
hear it when they hear it but I will say
this one thing they definitely will not
see this one coming
so here we go okay alright here we go
let's do it
all right thank you so much for
everything you do and I literally mean
everything because she does everything
we have been friends for like 15 years
and I am so blessed to have you in my
life
you truly are rare and special and I
couldn't think of a better time to give
you possibly the greatest gift I could
ever give you have fun at the Super Bowl
I'm so excited and I was like I probably
will never be able to talk this again
because I know you love realness
like you really are the greatest human
ever and you're so great at what you do
you show mention but you really are I
could never do everybody keeps asking me
like how I do everything I do and I
could not do that without you you make
everything work there's so much to say
Super Bowl Sunday she is the best
she is very generous and caring and she
makes me want to be a better person so
really I'm gonna start crying because I
can't talk about her
just cuz we've been friends for 15 years
and she's such a giving heart and I know
how much she cares about people no
matter if she knows them or doesn't know
them how much she does for people that
she doesn't tell anybody about and it's
just really cool to have someone in your
life like that
[Music]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this